ces vélos ont permis à des habitants de
fuir les villages de la région des
personnes occupées par les russes
les rubans blancs ont servi à les
identifier comme des civils
quand les gens ont essayé de fuir en
voiture les russes les ont arrêtés au
poste de contrôle ils ont fait sortir
des véhicules et leur ont dit de faire
demi tour ils ont également tiré sur les
voitures ou alors ils les ont confisqué
nous gardons les vélos pour que les
personnes puissent venir les chercher
après notre victoire mais certains
n'osent même pas prendre le vélo ce qui
les obligerait à passer par les routes
et les pistes tous les matins à ce poste
police telenoche que des personnes
arrivent qui ont fui la région des
personnes à pied ils perdent très tôt le
matin pour éviter les russes et font un
voyage de plusieurs heures à travers les
champs c'était pas ma peau cabanis
pirate
bay
mais
ramon a pris 9 08 réforme qui tique
auraient
à leur arrivée la police prend leurs
coordonnées
le couple est épuisé mais surtout
soulagé d'avoir échappé à l'occupant
russe
il me parlait comme un mettra son
esclave
ils attendent avec d'autres déplacés
qu'un bus les amène vers kiev projeter
la ligne de front cette région n'est pas
sûr
pour preuve ces armes qui ont atterri
récemment
[Musique]
il s'agit de roquettes tirées par les
forces russes sur des zones civiles
des bombes à fragmentation qui sont
interdites dans le monde entier
mais les russes les utilisent
les autorités affirment que malgré les
risques environ 40% de la population vit
toujours à zelenov sq